well guys they really did it as they so
often do just when I thought I was out
Nintendo has pulled me back in first off
a warning though the rest of this video
is essentially just me gushing over the
latest tears of the Kingdom trailer now
to be totally clear the game is not out
yet obviously we're just reacting to a
trailer here but knowing the history of
Nintendo and knowing the quality of
breath of the wild even though breath of
the wild was not my favorite game ever
made I enjoyed it I think it was a
really good game but there are still
elements that I would have preferred it
to be more of a traditional Zelda game
with all of the open World stuff and it
seems like it seems like fingers crossed
that that could be what we are getting
with tears at the Kingdom so as I said
in the beginning I think this trailer
had absolutely everything a good video
game trailer needs and it all started
with the music at the very very
beginning all you can hear is the wind
just the slow rustling of the wind and
then this lord of the rings-esque I've
heard a lot of people say that I totally
felt the same way right as if I have
just stepped into a fantasy world and
right away I was locked in it feels like
the humble beginnings of what is going
to be an Epic Journey then you get the
first shot of Link
foreign
[Music]
chills even listening to it again now
then as the trailer proceeds you get
these various shots of the landscape and
the music here just has me ready to go
out on an adventure I mean let's pack it
up let's go I'm ready to explore this
world right now but it doesn't stop
there of course you know it has to shift
into something more Sinister we see the
shot of Hyrule Castle Rising with the
malice all around it a brief moment
where it slows down a bit because we do
have some dialogue here and there and it
just keeps building up to the Ganondorf
reveal which is another one of my
favorite parts of the trailer and I
think growing up and having played so
many of these games I'd actually
forgotten how long it had been since we
saw a Ganondorf somebody in a comment on
another video that really the last time
we have seen him in this form was
Twilight Princess which blew me away
this game released all the way back in
2006. and we are in 2023 now so of
course Ganondorf has been alluded to and
we've seen versions of him demise and
then Ganon but this Ganondorf here in
his human warm it's been a while in the
trailer it's not even four minutes but
at the end I feel like I just watched an
Epic movie and the music plays such a
big role in that there are also several
other key story moments in addition to
the Ganondorf reveal now straight up I
don't claim to be an expert on all of
the many branching narratives throughout
the history of the Zelda franchise all
the timelines all that definitely not an
expert but what I do love about this
game is that it feels like the story is
going to be playing a much more Central
role and throughout the history of the
series we've seen them handle this in
different ways in some games the story
is more prominent in other games it kind
of takes more of a back seat I mean you
think about it took them forever just to
add voice acting at all now breath of
the wild had it but the majority of the
storytelling there was actually told
through these flashback cutscenes as
link regained his memory and I could be
wrong about this one because the trailer
certainly wants to show the game in the
best light but it at least feels to me
like this one is going to have a much
bigger story with multiple races
involved and even the regular people of
Hyrule seem to be getting in on the
action also Zelda where is she getting
sent to is it another realm another
dimension I think there are some strong
hints at time travel I really do take
the very final shot of the whole trailer
after the logo there's one more little
scene at the end and we see Zelda here
staring up into an empty Sky notice no
Sky Islands here and she's saying link
you have to find me so is this far in
the past could be far into the future I
mean the clothing that she's wearing
makes me think it's even more in the
past she definitely seems to be doing
something with the zonai and learning
about them so we're the zonai there all
along and they just went to a different
place a different dimension and that's
where she's went to or has she traveled
back in time right now I really feel
like it is time travel which I don't
really love in traditional media I don't
love it in books I don't love it in
movies but something about time travel
in Zelda it just works it always has
worked for me all the way back from when
I played Ocarina of Time I just loved
how they handled time travel there and
then I think we get our first shot at
the actual tears of the Kingdom we can
see Zelda with one here Ganondorf has
one I think all of the other Champions
have them as well and speaking of Tears
what is the connection to the tier on
Zelda's face and also this person here
is this the Goddess hylia that seems to
be the leading theory right now is this
Zelda in highly in form I mean there are
some definite similarities to Zelda but
also some key differences as well looks
like she actually has eight of these
tiers whereas Zelda only has two so is
that eventually who Zelda becomes I have
so many questions I even saw some people
saying maybe it's Zelda's mother I mean
who knows at this point right but my
early Theory right now and I'm
definitely still gonna put out a
separate Story video as well compiling
everything we saw from this trailer but
I think we're gonna have to go around
regaining each of these tiers and then
somehow send them back in time to Zelda
who is going to rebuild the master sword
I think for the majority of the game The
Master Sword is probably not going to be
in our hands obviously they have some
story reasons for it but also there are
some definite gameplay reasons for it
because they want us to use all these
other weapons and Creations that they
have made for the game and of course
once you get the Master Sword they have
to make it powerful enough to where you
don't want to even use the other weapons
anymore and we have to talk about the
gameplay too because as good as the
story elements are here I have always
personally believed that for a truly
great video game trailer and I mean a
great one you have to have gameplay I
get the Publishers they like to show off
cut scenes and cinematics because they
usually look better than the actual game
they look great on commercials and
Sizzle reels and I guess they sell I
mean I guess it works they probably know
better than me but for me myself as a
long time gamer show me the gameplay man
and boy did this trailer deliver on the
gameplay even after they just showed us
a what was it 13 minute gameplay demo
and even though the trailer was just
under four minutes long we saw so many
shots and they just happened so fast
they jump from one Epic gameplay scene
to the next you've got the hint at what
many think could be the return of
traditional Zelda dungeons so many
examples of all these new abilities that
link is gonna have in the game plus even
a quick look at some gameplay mechanics
that we haven't seen them show off
before and what about all these shots of
companions fighting alongside link we
have the new Champions who have grown up
a bit from the previous game and then
you even have the townsfolk who are
helping out joining Link in the battle
to save Hyrule and that one really
speaks both to the story and the
gameplay I mean we've seen some of this
like companion style gameplay before but
something about the way it's pictured
here I think it's going to be way more
prominent in this game I mean my early
thought is one tier for each Champion
one tier for each dungeon and one
companion for each of these which begs
the question if I'm right about my
theory of the tears repairing the master
sword how do we get that tier from Ganon
if you missed it and it's actually hard
to see it in the trailer but Nintendo
released some official artwork and it is
incredibly clear right here that that
jewel in the center of ganon's forehead
or Ganondorf excuse me it is 100 one of
the tiers that looks very similar to the
one that Zelda has except just a
different color of course oh and the
Triforce right how can we forget the
Triforce where is that going to factor
in you know what has to come into play
at some point but overall I mean I'm
officially I'm all in at this point guys
I am so ready for this game now this is
what they were missing I was optimistic
for it of course I've known Nintendo's
history but I needed something to really
make me say Wow to stand up and to cheer
and to really just send that height
meter into overdrive and this trailer
certainly did that a big part of that as
I've said how much I love gameplay it
was all these different gameplay
sections and I just had to make a
completely separate video on that
breaking down 10 of my favorite gameplay
reveals that we saw in this trailer make
sure you check that video out next I'll
link it here on the right side of your
screen also big shout out to all of our
channel members thank you guys so much
for all of your support as always thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon